so good afternoon everyone it's really a
pleasure to be back in New Haven
in my ears here and you I know you had a
big HIV meeting yesterday to some of you
go to that yeah so I'll be covering as
one of the civics that was covered in
the panel yesterday afternoon so i'll be
interested to hear what you all heard
from that panel as we get into the area
of seek test and treat but i just want
to begin by thinking about the big
picture you know and where we stand at
this moment in time and you don't really
need to see the detail on this map to
recognize that the global burden of HIV
disease is primarily in sub-saharan
africa not only obviously but what we
still see is that the the heaviest
burden of disease tends to be in those
countries where the health system is
really weakest in terms of numbers of
health providers and resources and I
think what we're really seeing overall
both in the United States as well as
globally is that we're really not seeing
the increased funding for HIV prevention
services that we used to see and yet we
have larger larger numbers absolute
numbers of people living with HIV so the
good news is that globally HIV
prevalence peaked some years back
incidents has dropped in a number of
countries including in sub-saharan
Africa and we have some new approaches
which we'll talk about a little bit
today antiretroviral containing
microbicides pre-exposure prophylaxis
some some some prevention strategies
test and treat that we'll talk about
combination HIV prevention that I think
give us some ways forward which is
encouraging and I think there's really a
movement globally and certainly in the
United States with our health reform to
think holistically about healthcare
systems and if we strengthen them for
HIV it might strengthen them for care
and delivery of other conditions for the
population as a whole so those are all I
think pluses we do know that HIV
prevention works okay global HIV
provincial working groups summarized has
summarized things in the last few years
study done a few years back showed that
HIV prevention is cost savings now bear
in mind not every intervention we do
Healthcare actually saves money so this
is actually something that really
effectively saves dollars and then in
fact if we had invested strategically
enough we really could avert half of all
new infections in this ten year time
period that they looked at in this study
but we have seen dramatic success in in
various countries Uganda had a dramatic
drop there may be some increasing
prevalence and incidence going on now
but Australia jumped very early on their
HIV epidemic among men have sex with men
for example Brazil has been a leader in
terms of making generic antiretroviral
drugs available very early on they've
been very forward-thinking in their
prevention and it's had a population
level impact so there are strategic
things we can do and we have a number of
interventions now that have varying
degrees of evidence about their
effectiveness from randomized trial
level down to sort of ecologica
sociation zeeeee and you can see for
prevention we have various approaches
for preventing transmission through
blood and tissue and then maternal to
child transmission which has been one of
the real success stories in HIV and
actually recently good information on
pre exposure prophylaxis to prevent
primary HIV infection among men who have
sex with men so what we're going to talk
about today is we're going to cover
talking about testing increasing
people's access to HIV serostatus
knowledge because that's the starting
point right for them for people to
receive health care that will save their
own lives extend the quality and length
of their own lives as well as to help
reduce transmission to others either
through sexual or parenteral
transmission we'll talk about treatment
antiretroviral therapy both as primary
HIV prevention and a secondary HIV
prevention that is to say prevention
with positives so trying to reduce
infectivity and transmission from
someone living with HIV to their sex or
needle sharing partners so we'll touch a
little bit on prep but i'm really going
to talk more about the testing street
strategy and a RT treatment as a whole
and then we'll close talking about
combination HIV prevention how many guys
have how many of you have heard about
combination HIV prevention
so it's a it's a kind of a current
buzzword and we'll talk about what it
might look like methodologically and
operationally so testing and treating we
do know that obviously people who don't
know their status can't act on their own
healthcare in an informed way right and
we know that probably twenty five
percent of people united states who are
living with HIV still don't know their
status so the CDC as well as a wh 0 have
really promoted the idea of expanded HIV
testing access that it's cost effective
in fact work done here at Yale David
Belle teal has shown several years back
that having every American 13 to 65 have
at least one HIV test and high risk
groups have an annual HIV test is cost
effective okay and that really push for
this policy expansion to say we really
have to have more folks get to know
their HIV status nonetheless we still
have 56,000 new HIV infections a year
right so we know we're not reaching
everyone to know about their status and
we're not doing as much with prevention
as we could be doing in sub-saharan
Africa remember that picture I showed
you two-thirds of all HIV and the people
living with HIV in the world live in
sub-saharan Africa access to HIV testing
has grown I work in Kenya and they've
done a tremendous job in increasing
voluntary counseling and testing and
I'll talk about some other strategies
they're using but nonetheless on the
whole it's about one in five people who
have actually been tested and who may be
at risk so late stage diagnosis is still
very much the norm people come in very
advanced in their HIV disease
unfortunately and we know it makes a
difference to know your status there
have been meta analyses that have been
done in the US and in other countries
showing that really for the most part
people who test positive change and
reduce their risk behaviors their
transmission risk behaviors so that's
been pretty consistent including a seven
countries study that was done showing
that voluntary counseling testing
recipients less likely to have
unprotected sex so fewer transmission
events not necessarily fewer number of
partners though okay i will say that so
I've worked with colleagues and
Mozambique we did an analysis
this of sexual behaviors before and
after 12 months after antiretroviral
therapy initiation and there were fewer
there was more condom use but there was
also more sex and there was also more
concurrent sexual partnerships which is
having sex with two or more people in
the same time period which we now
believe can be a real superhighway for
HIV transmission spread so in general it
sounds like a pretty unmitigated good
right everyone should know their HIV
status but in epidemiology and a public
health as you as you all know we always
have to think about the risks and
protective factors the positive and the
negative the unintended consequence and
so I would say that there is some
limited evidence that should make us
just you know have a little bit of a
caveat there been a couple of studies
project respect to which is which tested
rapid HIV testing same-day testing
versus standard antibody testing with a
two-week period and there was a study
done Zimbabwe which showed that actually
in the subgroup of men they had more
risk behavior after after they tested
okay so we do want to always think about
risk compensation will people take a
message hey I'm negative now I can go
out and have more protected sex because
I'm scot-free we do want to think about
that and you know really continue to
focus on evidence-based effective
primary and secondary prevention
strategies any of you health care
providers you work in health care
settings okay well if you talk to any
colleagues who do I think they would say
it's well recognized consistent in the
literature that we don't do a terribly
good job in assessing the sexual health
of our patients and our clients and
that's pretty consistent in surveys that
we've done over the years including an
HIV clinics now wouldn't you think you'd
want to talk to HIV positive patient
about how to protect themselves from
other st is that could affect their own
health or to reduce the risk of passing
HIV on to their sex partners makes sense
does it happen not always right for a
variety of reasons providers don't
always have the time the skill set the
motivations the resources so that's a
continuing problem
and they're not always offering HIV
testing either despite that policy
change that i mentioned that cdc
recommends we all do that now that we
recommend testing so we have to try to
think about creative ways what will
improve providers you know compliance
basically with with policy guidelines
and give more access do we need to put
prompts in emergency departments where
there are high risk folks who don't
always get off at HIV testing the FDA
has held hearings on self testing for
HIV so this will be over the counter
self-testing and then go in there are
trials underway right now looking at
self testing and really we want to reach
the highest risk folks those folks who
don't yet know their status right and so
they don't they can't benefit from
information about their CEO status and
treatment options so a couple of years
ago in Lancet a group from the Debra aho
put out a mathematical model and they
said really even without having an
effective HIV vaccine which we don't
have a highly effective HIV vaccine
right now if we could do a couple of
things we might be able to shift the
epidemic so what they said is if we have
universal HIV testing test everybody for
HIV and repeat that testing every year
as soon as someone test positive get
them on antiretroviral therapy
regardless of where they are in their
disease process or their cd4 count okay
we usually wait till people order a
certain dropped cd4 count to initiate
antiretroviral therapy and they all
stayed on their medicines forever did a
great job with adherence right then we
be able to transition from the current
endemic state to an elimination phase of
the epidemic within a five-year time
period and eventually over time reduce
incidence and mortality and then over a
longer period reduce prevalence so that
we get below they are not reproductive
rate of infection and basically the
epidemic dies out that was the model and
it was pretty provocative it got a lot
of people talking there were also a lot
of questions about about the model and
the the assumptions that were built into
it which were not very realistic
you know we don't have testing of
everybody and putting everybody right on
treatment although San Francisco General
Hospital has a new policy as soon as
someone tests positive they will put
them on antiretroviral therapy
regardless of their disease state so
it's an interesting exercise but in
general that's not available everywhere
there are other people who said look if
we if we do this where you know get
people on early treatment although it's
been shown in analysis of electronic
health record data to reduce mortality
nonetheless what's the what's the
downside you might increase viral
resistance right at the community level
and Sally blauer is a has done some
mathematical modeling of data in San
Francisco that suggests that that might
happen and we know that people don't
always take their medicines none of us
do right so what's the average adherence
to hypertensive antihypertensive
medicines in the United States can you
guess
fifty percent okay antiretroviral
therapy it's about 75% the United States
is better in Africa actually so you know
it's hard to take pills every day right
and so the fact that people don't always
take their medicines in real life not in
a clinical trial where they're coming in
and they're very compliant and they're
getting incentives and support in
everything else might mean they would
wipe out any potential benefit from
providing antiretroviral therapy that
can presumably knock down people's
infective atif in their sexual fluids of
HIV right and there was actually a study
in China that came out recently amongst
discordant couples that really didn't
see any reduction in transmission to the
negative partner in a real world kind of
setting my colleague Tim hallett who had
also knows was a mathematical model from
Imperial College he's actually done some
modeling to show that actually
paradoxically if you don't have good
coverage if you don't really get that
testing out to everybody and really get
that treatment out to everybody you
might actually end up having higher
long-term antiretroviral therapy costs
so it's really dependent on the the
epidemiologic and service structure in
it in a context to see if it really
would be cost effective so there are
some and David pelletier again who's
done who did the original HIV testing
cost effectiveness study here at Yale
he's actually shown in some washington
DC data that this idea of test and treat
will probably increase the lifespan of
people who are positive but it may not
knock down incidents at least in a five
year time period and we'll come back to
washington DC because there is a major
seat test and treat study on your way in
DC that i'll tell you about but here's
the basic idea right let's let people
know their status those who are positive
can get treatment and options that will
reduce the viral load in their plasma
now plasma viral load and general
compartment viral load are not always
completely synonymous but anyway it
should knock down infectivity so if they
do have unprotected sex or do share
needles you know hopefully it will
result overall and reduce transmission
and we have you know this whole idea of
treatment for prevention we have data
from Tom Quinn that's now you know
the classic study from done in in Africa
showing that there really is a
dose-response between the amount of
virus in a person's body and the sexual
transmission probability to their
partner and related to the disease stage
and and how much viral Barlow they have
and again thinking about the natural
history of HIV disease there's differing
probabilities of transmission at
different stages when someone first gets
infected and they've just loaded up with
virus in the acute phase you know its
transmission is much more likely but
that's a very short time period in terms
of exposure that sex partners may have
and also in terms of a program being
able to deliver an acute HIV prevention
intervention right but then people live
for a very long period of time and what
we've you know think of as the latent
phase there's a lot going on when they
feel fine they're not going to maine
ah'd know the status and yet there's a
long period of time where they might be
having sex unprotected sex or I'm needle
change so that's a very long time period
to contribute to transmission at the
population level and then when people
are very sick again the viral load goes
up if they're not on treatment but they
probably don't feel well enough to be
having opportunity set so we have to
think about sort of the natural history
and where are our prevention windows or
targets you know where we can actually
deliver interventions to reduce
susceptibility amongst HIV negatives and
reduce infectivity amongst HIV positives
right so negatives that's a number of
years that we should we have to deliver
effective prevention people who are have
been exposed but we may have a very very
brief window of out literally 72 hours
to try to intervene with a prophylaxis
post-exposure prophylaxis is very short
window and then when people are already
infected obviously they can live for
many years and again we want to support
prevention with positives so minute
several meta analyses have shown that
delivering interventions prevention with
positive interventions with people
living with HIV
can be effective and they're more
effective if they contain these elements
and our delivered in HIV care settings
so again we know we have evidence that
working with people living with HIV to
reduce transmission risk is effective
now does every HIV clinic have an
evidence-based prevention with positives
program being delivered it efficiently
to everybody now and we've actually put
a lot of the elements of evidence-based
counseling approaches into a computer
tool so that hopefully that'd be one
mechanism for patients to get access to
that information in clinics so we know
that counseling and testing it may be
helpful particularly couples testing and
this is kind of a new area that people
are looking at a lot of the HIV
transmission in Africa for example
occurs among stable heterosexual couples
people who are married people who are
together for a long period of time
that's actually where a lot of the risk
and the transmission is happening so
couples oriented counseling is something
we're looking at more we've talked about
antiretroviral therapy we have a large
trial as on going to see if giving the
positive person a territorial therapy
actually reduces transmission in the
meantime we have observational data that
i'll tell you about that's quite
promising and then in the in the global
context it may be the case that if we
treat co-infections that can often bump
up the HIV viral load that might be a
way to help also reduce infectivity so
my colleague Connie Callum who's at
University of Washington she's done a
multi study number of multi study trials
HIV prevention trials and in the context
of one of her cohort studies she was
able to look at amongst discordant
couples a discordant you know one person
is HIV the other one doesn't sexual
couples she was able to show that when
that positive partner went on the
positive partners went on antiretroviral
therapy it dramatically reduced the risk
of transmission to the sexual partners
okay so as a ninety two percent
reduction adjusted relative risk that
wasn't the purpose of the study but
they're able to look at the data and see
that effect right and in fact the one
transmission that did happen among
someone who was on a charge of viral
therapy it clearly happened when that
person still had a very high viral
ode and adjust gotten on to therapy and
the transmission event probably happened
here before that person's viral load
went to undetectable and the highest
rate of transmission occurred amongst
those people whose cd4 counts were below
200 now that's pretty much the minimum
treatment threshold for a lot of
low-income countries the World Health
Organization now recommends that people
start at her trial therapy at 350 when
they're healthier a lot of countries
can't afford that so they start at two
hundred and so what Connie has seen in
her data is that well at least that's
the group you do want to focus on get
get those folks on antiretroviral
therapy because higher rate of
transmission events and for those folks
who are above 200 then you really want
to look at those folks who have very
high viral loads so about 50,000 copies
this all makes perfect sense logically
it's just good to see the data right
because resources are limited right
those people who are clinically eligible
for antiretroviral therapy globally
right now it may be thirty percent forty
percent of people who should be on air
of a RT are on a RT so we have to think
about really targeting our resources so
this is a way to think about targeting
at least in terms of reducing infection
so again this ninety two percent
reduction in the partners study was very
very suggestive very interesting but it
is important to say we've had internet
for all therapy United States for
example for a long time we still had
56,000 new infections a year right and
people have looked at an ecological
level at the association between
introduction of antiretroviral therapy
and transmission and some suggested in
Vancouver that there was a positive
impact other studies have not seen that
again it's an ecological approach it's
not it's not it's got all the problems
of ecologic studies we have problems
with the incidents assays that we use so
I guess I would just say as a reminder
there's a the idea of test and treat has
a lot of Appeal a lot of biological
plausibility but it's not necessarily
going to be the one you know magic
bullet
thinking about treatment for a primary
prevention now to prevent infection for
in- people the kesha Boris study this
was a multi-country study that looked at
hiv-positive moms continuing their
antiretroviral therapy beyond delivery
into the breastfeeding period because as
you know transmission can happen at any
one of those stages antepartum
intrapartum postpartum through breast
milk and there were really very
encouraging data from that it reduced
the postpartum transmission rate by over
forty percent so this is the idea of
treatment to prevent transmission to a
negative person in this case the child
after many years in the wilderness we
finally have good data on a micro beside
that has worked so in South Africa the
caprices study found that they enrolled
HIV negative women and there was a at
the end of the study thirty-nine percent
effectiveness in reducing incident HIV
and interesting again to note the
effectiveness was better amongst the
women who self-reported being more
adherent to using the micro beside right
so again we think about these biomedical
interventions they don't function in a
vacuum people still have to use
behaviors to use the biomedical
interventions effectively so we had to
think about behavioral adherence to all
of these interventions over time
pre-exposure prophylaxis we now have
data again in this last year on
effectiveness for reducing HIV
transmission amongst men who have sex
with men so that was very encouraging
reduced infection by a minha forty-four
percent and again it was a higher
reduction amongst the men who are more
adherent to using it and we will be
hearing more pre-exposure prophylaxis
data in the next two years will be
coming out of trials so the voice trial
is coming which is looking at negative
sexual women we have other prep studies
coming and amongst other populations so
we're going to be seeing more
information about prep and now it really
becomes this issue of implementation so
you're at the Health Department are you
guys doing anything with prep for MSM
did you come out with any guidance after
the CDC yeah so they've a camera so this
is feeding the Nationals he does he came
out with an interim guidance now every
Health Department state health
department every has to figure out how
do we actually implement this how are we
going to deliver prep to the highest
risk MSM or whichever population it's
been shown efficacy in right and it's
not going to be easy to do now we can
learn from our colleagues and family
planning because they've been for
decades they've had to you know roll out
new contraceptions and contraceptive
services and to end tools right and they
have to understand the acceptability and
feasibility and operational delivery for
those those new devices and pills and so
forth but it is not going to be easy to
get pre exposure prophylaxis out there
paid for you know when we again remember
what I said people who already have HIV
aren't all on antiretroviral therapy now
we're going to be given antiretrovirals
to negative people so you can see the
competing demands right in terms of
resources how do policymakers figure
that out will it lead to risk
compensation or disinhibition right now
I'm protected I've got you know I think
I can go out have more unprotected sex
so I just think there's going to be some
real competing issues and sustainability
questions even though again it's
exciting that we have more of evidence
about efficacy other tools in our tool
kit for prevention and of course you
know we still have condoms but they
remain the redhead is a stepchild
basically right we don't have any RCTs
because why you can't randomize
ethically randomized condom use but we
know ecologically and from other other
sources of data that they're effective
but frankly you know they don't get used
as often as they could but they
certainly need to be a component of our
prevention approaches so I'm just going
to talk about a current test and treat
kind of study that is being funded right
now in the United States this is HPT an
HIV prevention trial Network 065 it's a
the person who leads this is waffle
solder and Bernie Branson at Columbia
and CDC and basically this is a very
large very ambitious kind of community
study that's being done in the Bronx and
in Washington DC also looking at
surveillance data in four
parador cities just to look at trends
but it's a huge study and all its going
to talk about is feasibility of a test
and treat approach okay we're not
there's no way you can look at an HIV
incident outcome in the United States we
don't have the power of the resources
for it so it's really just a feasibility
study and what it's involving is a
couple of things it's building on some
campaigns that have been undertaken in
the Bronson or DC to try to encourage
more HIV testing right so this is the
everybody needs to know in the NDC
they're working with all the hospitals
in those two cities to try to get more
testing done in the emergency
departments and in the inpatient setting
they are randomizing some sites that
they will give a coupon to the person
who test positive if they go to a clinic
and HIV care clinic so this is this idea
of behavioral economics conditional cash
transfer give people money for the
behavior that you want them to do a
little bit controversial some evidence
of effectiveness though then another
component is that they are randomizing
some of the HIV clinics in those two
cities to also pay the person if their
viral load goes to undetectable after
two visits so they're being paid to get
to a viral undetectable viral load right
again that's what we want to walk out
for their own health and for
transmission risk and then there's a
component that that I'm working on which
is we also need to support people who
are identified as being positive right
our goals to go out there and find out
everyone is actually positive push them
into care now what now we have to help
keep them sustaining care and give
support around prevention with positives
around transmission risk reduction so
we're using a computer tool that I've
developed in the past with colleagues
and we're going to be doing us just a
traditional nested randomized trial
within this larger study to look at self
reported sexual transmission risk and
how many partners they're having sex
with who are known to be HIV negative or
who's HIV status they don't know so
we're looking at transmission risk and
delivering an evidence-based counseling
prevention with positives counseling
intervention on the tablet computer it's
all audio narrator in English or Spanish
so it's between that person and the
computer basically
and this is just you know to give you an
idea of it the tablet we currently have
a study of 500 people in in New York
City using a similar tool that's being
done in Spanish and we're starting a
randomized trial and Kenya that's been
done in Swahili so it kind of delivers a
counseling session that an optimal
counselor would but not every place has
the staffing for that right so we've
gone from this language of test and
treat from that original granite model
that said you know we can end the
epidemic just by testing and treating
right then we said well actually it's
not that simple we really have to test
and then help we have to go find people
at risk encourage them to get tested
help them get into treatment help keep
them on treatment so now the evolution
of this tech this language is really
seek test treat and retain that's the
very latest if you want to have the
latest buzzword that that's it and the
NH has funded several initiatives around
this one of which is focused in
correctional facilities so I'm working
with colleagues that in Rhode Island and
watch the Washington DC jails of for an
initiative there Fred altise who's here
at Yale he's also part of this
initiative he has project a project
going on and there's now a new round of
funding that they're looking to make
awards for this concept of sheet treat
and retain in low-income countries so
let's shift now to this idea of
combination prevention we want to take
effective evidence-based approaches
package them up deliver them to the
right population and have high enough
coverage that we can have an impact this
is basically the same concept this is a
kind of a term that was coined by our
mentor King homes at University of
Washington just like we have highly
active antiretroviral therapy that works
biologically on the virus we need highly
active multiple component prevention as
well
so that rather than kind of doing what
we often do which is you know we develop
an intervention we tested in a single
RCT that takes five years to do and then
you do the men that takes a couple years
to come out in the literature the idea
is to move it more towards combining
effective interventions so that we can
ideally have an impact at the population
level and in a way that's sustainable
and really the hope here is that by
doing this in a more thoughtful way we
really could gain synergy right that's
the goal that it wouldn't just be an
additive fact but you know you really
have some synergistic effects so this is
a mathematical model that just shows you
know it gives a quick visual of what
that could look like if you don't
intervene what the incidence per 100
person-years might be if you only
deliver male circumcision which we know
is effective but if you just do that by
itself you get that if you only
delivered Risk Reduction behavioral
interventions to get that but if you put
it together you get synergy that's the
hope that's the goal so there haven't
been a lot of these studies done yet as
such and so there you know it's sort of
a newer area there are a couple of
different approaches people are taking
some are combining you know one or more
interventions in a package and I'll tell
you about this NIH funded initiative mp3
initiative and working with colleagues
on one project now others are sort of
looking in terms of focusing on
subpopulations the most risk populations
and so designing you know sort of
packages of things specific to a
population and then others are also
trying to sort of look at structural
factors as well and really put it
together in a way that that would be
working with with with the community so
again these packages will need to
include evidence-based behavioral
elements what do we know works from
biomedical interventions
and the structural intervention piece is
often left out but really is critical
when you think about it right what puts
people at risk what enhances individuals
risks it has to do with a lot of those
structural issues you know gender
inequality homophobia laws against
needle you know use so people have been
trying to look at ways to also
incorporate structural intervention
changes and it can get pretty
complicated looking right so here we go
here's here's the biomedical behavioral
structural list of interventions right
all useful have varying levels of
evidence around them how do you put that
together how do you choose really what's
going to go in that basket how do you
deliver it at a high enough coverage
level to have an impact how do you
evaluate what impact you have so there's
some really interesting but challenging
methodologic concerns around this and in
general people say you know again it's
it's it's taking that same idea that
we've had for a while you really need to
know your epidemic HIV is really about
micro epidemics you have to know your
specific patterns in a subpopulation
who's the most at risk you've got to
deliver evidence-based interventions
that reduce susceptibility and/or
infectivity right you want to cover the
whole gamut and again you have to hope
that you're putting them in the right
place in a cost-effective way so again
thinking back to our windows of
prevention intervention we have
opportunities to deliver interventions
prior to HIV exposure at during the
point of a possible transmission and
then following infection in terms of
people living with their HIV after
infection so how do you pick how do you
choose evidence okay we've all seen that
pyramid of strength of evidence right
you know sort of case series versus a
cohort versus a single RCT versus
multiple RCT systematic reviews right
well we don't have every level of
evidence for all of the interventions
but again I think it's it's follows a
sort of logical pattern we need to
understand the epidemic and the patterns
that we're trying to focus on where do
we get data for that what are the main
drivers of the epic
in that group so it's if it's
heterosexual couples in sub-saharan
Africa you know what are the main things
that are putting people at risk and what
would be the best intervention points
and then you know choosing the effective
interventions so there have been
strength of evidence ratings like the US
Preventive Services Task Force right has
the ratings of levels of evidence for an
event of CDC's done something similar so
that may be one approach that people
will use and you know there again as
with the seat test treat and retain idea
there's some concerns or criticisms
people have about combination HIV
prevention misunderstanding that it kind
of means throwing everything into the
kitchen sink well that's not going to be
good right that won't be working some
people say you know you just you just
can't do it the way you're talking about
designing these things and evaluating it
but actually there have been some
existing studies and projects that
really essentially have been combination
HIV prevention that have followed some
of these techniques and so and they've
been carried out successfully I can look
in India among female sex workers other
concerns are around cost but then
against yes compared to what doing
single interventions or not doing
anything that's effective or spending
money on interventions that actually
aren't effective right which which
certainly can happen so the goal with
the thought would be that if we if we do
get synergies it might be you know more
cost-effective it might allow economies
of scale to be delivered we have to look
for antagonisms though between the
interventions in these packages hard to
evaluate no question about it they're
real method logic challenges here to
doing that and to thinking through
causal chain and trying to parse out
what the impact is and as with all HIV
prevention studies you know we have big
challenges you need you need a place
with high incidence to have enough power
to carry out a cost effective study we
don't have the we saw problems with our
incidence assays and so we need really
innovative designs and analytic
strategies and
those are going to be developed as we as
we go forward and there is really a
reliance on using mathematical modeling
as a tool for all this as a way to sift
through well what if we you know we read
the literature we do a systematic review
what are the most effective HIV
prevention interventions for adolescents
which by the way there isn't much of an
evidence base well now let's all right
let's put it into the model so we're
hoping to do a combination prevention
study in Kenya looks like we'll get
funded for where we're going to do
gender specific packages for boys versus
girls because there's different things
that are needed different risk different
interventions so how do we select
amongst those we can model it if we
picked male circumcision and alcohol
reduction you know alcohol abuse
reduction and this for the for the boys
what would that do as opposed to if we
took this this intervention out put that
one in right so there really is a
utility to use in these mathematical
models which of course are only as good
as the parameters that go into them and
that are not empiricism right their
models but they can still help us choose
amongst interventions and also to sort
of potentially look at evaluating impact
so this was again Tim hallett at
Imperial College he looked this in Bob
way interventions that were done by by
that happened on the ground and you know
there was a dramatic drop in in
prevalence and incidence in Zimbabwe
probably initially because the
susceptibles died out that's what you
see here but then over time and there's
been a lot of discussion recently about
Zimbabwe and what's what's accounted for
this drop civil they had you know a lot
of civil distress unrest huge economic
crises men had less money to have
multiple partners and people reduce the
number of partners they had right and
that could have an impact so this is an
issue since this Zimbabwe model is an
interesting one because they've actually
put this together as a toolkit that's
available on the on the web as a free
sort of accessible tool to look at for
doing your own modeling so NIH has
funded a first round of these
combination HIV prevention grants and
their people are doing an interesting
range of things some people are looking
at MSM in
in Peru kind of Callum is working with
heterosexual couples in Uganda which
I'll tell you about Don deja la is
working with ID use in Estonia other
people are looking at they're taking one
village in Botswana and doing a whole
combination package just for that
village other people are looking at try
and identify acute HIV infection of
Malawi and deliver interventions there
but as I mentioned there's definitely a
lot of method logic concerns and I guess
opportunities you know for trying to
target your population target your
interventions think about how you
deliver them in a operational acceptable
way how might you evaluate it when you
don't have tens of millions of dollars
they just won't be tens millions dollars
for for these six even these six studies
to move forward to an efficacy trial
phase right and how would we identify
synergy antagonism whether there's been
added or multiplicative effects of
having these multiple interventions in a
package so the project that we have in
Uganda that Connie Kellam is running in
Uganda you can see how it walks through
the the approach is recommended for
combination prevention we're looking at
the drivers of the epidemic among
heterosexuals in sub-saharan Africa so
they've been systematic reviews
mathematical modelling then we decided
to launch a pilot to look a feasibility
of using using google phones and doing
home based testing with our NGO partner
there to basically use home based
testing as a way to deliver a targeted
prevention package to the couple in that
room so if it's a you know if it's a HIV
negative man who's uncircumcised his
wife is positive is he's a very
high-risk man we recommend a male
circumcision right and we actually have
ways to refer and to follow up on those
referrals so the idea is to try to
target the prevention package specific
to that person in their household and
we've done the pilot now we're going to
wrap up next month actually so we've
enrolled the number of households this
is sort of door-to-door household HIV
testing and we've identified it every
people who've not been tested before and
have been able to deliver the the
targeted prevention prescription for
them and we're following up on how how
good the uptake is so again its
feasibility but but now dr. Kalam is is
looking at taking that same model and
trying to expand it in South Africa and
elsewhere I'm also doing a kind of a
home-based I'm utilizing home-based HIV
testing as well this is a community of
rural cohort study we have in western
kenya we're actually doing probability
sampling using latitude and longitude
points so it's an actual probability
sample we go to households are our staff
feel staff have to work pretty hard and
they do HIV and pregnancy testing in the
house as you can see here where all the
sampling points are even if it puts you
in the middle of the sugarcane
plantation of the rice paddy you then
have an algorithm for finding the
closest house and offering people to
enroll in the study and what we're
finding and this is western kenya that's
had a lot of initiatives what in
one-in-four households one or both of
heterosexual couples are HIV positive
thirteen percent of women are pregnant
that day two percent in there were
pregnant and positive so this is really
high disease burden and we're really
doing this study to look at how we do a
better job of integrating people's
desires to have children which is a
really powerful desire with reducing
transmission risk when there's so much
HIV around right so when we think about
these combination prevention studies as
I said they're really it's it's newer to
think about it in a very rigorous way we
are really talking about feasibility
studies at this point well how do we get
it to the next level of saying is it is
it you know where's the efficacy much
less the effectiveness right so what do
you what would you do for a phase 3
study of a prevention package this now
maybe six things in it instead of just
one so people are looking at different
approaches one big question is do you
really try to do it as a randomized
trial or do you try to do it as a
demonstration project you know like in
one area which may have you know better
public health implications or
information to give so you know it's not
all about just having a randomized trial
for everything and there are some
difficulties doing a cluster randomized
trial for example you need at least six
pair of communities well it's actually
to find that with high incidence
ironically enough factorial designs you
know where you hope to get sort of two
for the price of one studies that works
unless the the multiple interventions
are not independent and so if you
question as always with HIV vention is
what's your comparator and and when the
standard of care for HIV prevention is
changing as you go it's hard to to be
able to assess that so right now
actually the CDC has an RFA out for one
they're going to find 120 million dollar
project to evaluate the efficacy of a
combination prevention study there's not
many places you can actually do this in
the world and they have very very
rigorous levels that they've set out for
how much coverage you have to show and
how much impact you have to show they
basically yeah so it's going to be very
interested to see who gets funding for
that and who can pull that one off but
at least there will be at least one
efficacy study so other study design
issues you know you really want to think
about are you testing the package as a
whole or testing its individual
components you're going to look at
biomarker outcomes or sort of process
measures you know you really are having
multiple targets and in a way you're
measuring the outcome on people who are
different from the ones who might have
been delivered the intervention right
when you think about Android device for
for prevention we've talked a bit about
some of the issues with HIV incidence
essays heart not per being perfect so
there are some other surrogate ways to
look at that process outcomes are
helpful actually to inform us about what
works in a program or what doesn't and
so Jim uses a biostatistician has sort
of laid out some some principles and
when you think about designing these
combination prevention packages you know
if you don't know the effect of the
various interventions that just do a
standard RCT but in general the ideas
that we should probably avoid mixing
interventions that are known and unknown
outcome and if we know the individual
components are efficacious then really
looking at the process and the
feasibility measures might be enough so
just to wrap up here you know we we know
that we're still having multiple new
cases of HIV for everybody who does get
put on therapy
we have to think of ways to do better
integration of evidence-based approaches
need to understand what's called an
implementation science better how do we
actually get the science that we do know
works out there into population level
practices this is a whole new area now
and we can just you know in going
quickly through UN aids we know that the
the approaches that work aren't actually
out there at the high enough coverage
levels they should be so this is just
coverage for a sex worker prevention MSM
and IBU its decline from 2008 to 2010
availability of sterile syringes
terrible there's been no needle exchange
in sub-saharan Africa although the
government can you just agreed to do
that and we're hoping to evaluate it it
prevention of maternal and child
transmission the complete success story
in HIV complete success story and yet
what are the coverage levels this is
antenatal coverage and this is pmtct
coverage look at Nigeria lata
hiv-positive pregnant women they're not
coming in for much antenatal care and
they're not getting much p.m. CT CT
right medical male circumcision
beautiful three rcts you never see
confidence intervals that close together
we know this works right and in fact we
know from modeling that it has an even
bigger impact than we thought because
there may be some helpful effect of
transmission for male to female and yet
how rolled out is it so this is this is
un aids 2010 data a small number of
sites in these high burden countries
numbers circumsized I mean you know
small numbers this right here the 90,000
people in yonder those quwanga agate who
was our colleague at University of
Washington she had her field staff out
there she did 40,000 circumcisions in a
month so it can be done but you have to
have the resources in the commitment and
we know it makes a difference if you
really scale up the interventions look
at this difference 25 million infections
can be averted if we scaled up what we
know works what we have now and so we
really do need to look at doing that
globally the combination approach really
might be helpful
and so I would say you know in some that
even in lieu of a vaccine which we won't
have a highly effective vaccine anytime
soon we do have ways to control the
pandemic and as always it's still about
political will it's about the resources
and it's about working with the
community so that is always going to be
the same